tonight we are all afraid
action a haunting in Venice has that
sort of not in the stomach edge of the
seat quality won't you forgive me you've
got to give them that precarious thrill
of being in this really quite haunting
Palazzo I think pot was really appealing
from the very first read of the script
was the Palazzo was a character some
things can't be seen
venison itself conjures up ideas of
Darkness you think of those old Gothic
buildings and the history of the place I
remember walking onto the set for the
first time it has set all the right
tones it's as terrifying and ominous and
interesting as it needs to be this is
not too frightening for the children
this set you can really walk through it
like a house
this is a remarkable Palazzo Ken likes
to work in a way that you feel the
environment is at 360 completely
believable world that we we inhabit we
try to find those ways to look at Venice
that took you there but made you feel
unsettled kind of exciting unsettled
quality
that's such a fun thing to do
if someone wants to be heard
we are here